good afternoon everyone thank you so
much for joining us both in person and
on Zoom hybrid let me start by thanking
Professor Carol mcgradeahan for joining
us uh at the refugee seminar series and
thanking the capable
um help of uh Teresa Delgado for for
arranging uh this visit it is and this
spec like a really wonderful honor to
have Piero uh join she's been a mentor
and she's one of the stars of
anthropology and Refugee studies
Professor mcgrada hun is a cultural
Anthropologist and historian
specializing in contemporary Tupac the
research focuses on issues on
colonialism and empire history and
memory power and politics refugees and
citizenship nationalism senses of
belonging gender war and anthropology is
theoretical storytelling since 94 she is
considered researching Tibetan Refugee
communities in India and Nepal on the
history and politics of gorilla
resistance between 1950 and 1974 which
culminated in her book arrested
histories Tibet the CIA and the and
histories of Forgotten of a forgotten
Noir it came out in 2010 with Duke
University press thinking of 20th and
21st century Tibetan histories and
experiences as Imperial in a global
sense is a key part of her work in
relation to the CIA British India and
the People's Republic of China Professor
mcgrana has worked on Empire Beyond
Europe can be found in unedited volume
Imperial formations which came out in
2007 it was co-edited with by Ann
staller and Peter Perdue as well and in
ethnographies of U.S Empire which came
out in 2018 co-edited with John Collins
currently Professor McGregor has is
completing a book about the pink debts
thank you
family
Tibet and British India in the first
half of the 20th century and she's
finishing a decade of research in France
India and Nepal New York City
Switzerland and Toronto titled Refugee
citizenship Asylum refusal and political
subjectivity in the Tibetan diaspora
she's presenting from that research
today a talk titled refusal as political
practice an ethnography of citizenship
and Refugee status please help me
welcome her today
[Applause]
like to say thank you to Ada Pepe and to
everyone at Yale for inviting me to be
here
um it's my pleasure to be able to share
this research with you
so the first time I went to Toronto all
everyone was talking about was political
Asylum and gaining convention Refugee
status
but people weren't just talking about it
they were joking about it there was one
joke we heard everywhere we went it went
something like this have you heard about
the sherpa guy who posed as a Tibetan in
Asylum Court the judge asked him when
the Dalai Lama's birthday was and the
man answered
Saturday
everyone who told the joke roared with
laughter at the punchline
no matter how many times it was told to
kesang and me in this friend's apartment
or that one ke song would laugh so hard
she had to wipe away tears the joke was
funny because of course every Tibetan
knows that the Dalai Lama's birthday was
July 6th yet in India Nepal his birthday
is usually not celebrated exactly on the
6th but instead is celebrated on
Saturday which is kind of the national
holiday
kind of the one day holiday right in a
six day work week the Bida the truthy
well all Tibetans know this they also
know that most Sherpas wouldn't know
this as the sherpa Community typically
does not celebrate the Dalai Lama's
birthday for que song and her friends
the joke was humorous commentary on
Tibetan and Himalayan immigration to
North America on a shared experience of
the Asylum system and the political
possibilities embedded in the idea of
citizenship
as an anthropologist on the alert for a
new research project when I heard the
joke for the fifth sixth seventh time I
knew this was it in order to understand
why this was happening in Canada however
we also have to consider the broader
context which is tibetan's six Decades
of refusing citizenship in South Asia
the history behind their immigration to
the United States and then often on to
Canada and why the sherpa man was posing
as a Tibetan in the first place
25 years ago if you drove or walked past
the U.S embassy in Kathmandu you would
have seen a long queue of people lined
up outside and on some days many of them
were Tibetan and as gossip went some of
those in line were pretending they were
Tibetan
they were young takali or manangi or
Sherpa men some of whom had shaved their
heads dawned maroon robes and pretended
to be monks based on a perceived notion
of Tibetan desirability that they hoped
would get them a rare U.S visa One Day
in 1998 kaisong and I stood in the queue
with a friend we calmed her nerves by
talking about the embassy official
everyone referred to as Mr David
supposedly he was a Buddhist and he
liked Tibetans and so if you were a
Tibetan or successfully convinced
Embassy staff that you were one your
chances of receiving a Visa were
believed to be good
sought after in this process was a
tourist visa which with one would enter
the United States and stay Beyond its
expiration
with the intention of somehow someway
securing a job in the USA so that you
could send money home to your family
after several hours of waiting outside
the embassy our friend emerged
victorious she had received a Visa
although none of us knew it back in that
day on 1998. almost 20 years later both
she and kaisong would be living in
Toronto as Canadian citizens in the span
of time a major ship shift happened in
the Tibetan Refugee Community with
thousands of individuals migrating from
South Asia to North America
that first visit that I made to Toronto
wasn't only about jokes there was also
serious reflection
all I have are stories a book of stories
Pepe said this to me as we sat in the
Shangri-La Tibetan restaurant in Toronto
on a snowy December night in 2007. I had
asked about her generation's experiences
of emigrating from South Asia to North
America
although she was now a 20 year old woman
we had known each other since she was a
six-year-old girl in Kathmandu and I was
a young graduate student just beginning
my research with the Tibetan Refugee
community
she and her mother had just moved to
Canada and I was visiting them there for
the first time again this is in 2007.
our belly's full of shutdown
we left the restaurant and walked back
to her apartment where her mother
kissong was waiting for us we greeted
her and settled in around the table
excuse me Pepe turned back to our
earlier conversation
the issues we are facing are papers
money and rights she said citizenship
papers money for everything and the
right to protest kaisung joined in
saying we didn't have any of those in
Nepal Tibetans didn't have papers money
or rights there she referring to Pepe
was born in Nepal but couldn't be a
citizen Pepe was not alone in this for
six decades Tibetan refugees have lived
in South Asia without citizenship
Tibetans refused to decision citizenship
in South Asia to both claim sovereignty
in Tibet and to assert political
equality and interdependence vis-a-vis
the governments of India and Nepal as
Tibetans like Pepe and Quezon moved to
North America their refusal as political
practice changes in some ways though it
Remains the Same in others for people
who have been collectively dispossessed
what does it mean to refuse
International Norms of citizenship by
insisting on a sovereignty that has been
lost
in the case of Tibet refusing
citizenship in South Asia is a means of
claiming past present and future State
sovereignty Tibet was Tibet is Tibet
will be this claim challenges globally
hegemonic formulas for sovereignty and
citizenship it rejects the idea that the
state of Tibet is merely a former
political entity and instead asserts
contemporary political legitimacy yet
what happens to political claims
embedded in refusal when refugees become
citizens elsewhere
how might refusal be reconfigured to
maintain political claims to home and
state sovereignty the seeming
contradiction of Tibetan refugees
accepting citizenship in North America
after Decades of refusing it in South
Asia demonstrates that hegemonic
categories and practices need not be
debilitating or total
tibetan's Collective refusal of an
externally assigned political status
posits a different status in its place
in so doing it refuses the probable in
favor of the possible
so in this paper I argue that the
unfolding history of the Tibetan Refugee
citizenship documentation and migration
challenges contemporary norms and
possibilities for political status
tibetan's in Exile do so first
by inhabiting to ostensibly oppose right
categories that of refugee and Citizen
and they do so second by refusing to
accept their sovereignty as past tense
that is
their current status regardless of
whether it's Refugee or undocumented or
stateless or citizen rests in a
temporality guided as much by a Buddhist
sense of impermanence as by an
irreverence for international norms
strategies might change but the goal
Remains the Same regaining Tibetan
sovereignty in Tibet
so I also want to argue that
ethnographic knowledge is vital for
understanding experiences of refugees
that is alongside political historic or
legal knowledge for example ethnography
provides us with a unique and
complementary way of knowing
specifically ethnographic research gives
us conceptual insights to life has lived
to how structures feel to how categories
are experienced and importantly into
Worlds of both action and agency which
for so long have been denied to refugees
my research with the Tibetan Community
spans over three decades and involves
personal and political commitments as
well as the relationships and
ethnographies that are at the heart
sorry relationships and obligations that
are at the heart of ethnography
and I first met in 1994. you can see us
here this is outside of the airport in
Kathmandu
she and I have been close ever since
sharing Joys and Sorrows over three
decades in three separate countries
including just a few weeks ago you can
see the photo here about a decade ago
we're at Niagara Falls
and then this photo which was taken in
October of this year
my second argument is about refusal as
21st century intervention into
possibilities for citizenship and
sovereignty
by this I do not mean the refusal of
immigration judges or officials who deny
passage deny recognition Asylum status
to people instead I mean refusal as a
willful conscious political Act
to refuse can be generative and
strategic a deliberate move toward one
thing belief practice or community and
away from another
the generative aspect of refusal
recognizes the sociality of saying no in
order to build something different
this affiliative aspect is one of the
things that Link's refusal to resistance
but refusal is not a synonym for
resistance where resistance involves
consciously defying or opposing
superiors in a context of differential
power relationships between State and
Society refusal rejects such a hierarchy
also rejects subjugation as the position
from which action is taken instead
refusal reposits relationships as
between equals insisting on Equity
rather than inequity
and so here in referring to refusal I
draw on the important research of
anthropologist Audrey Simpson for whom
refusal is both ethnographic and
political both stance and Theory Simpson
is one of the scholars in indigenous
studies leading the way in theorizing
refusal I think you're also of the work
of Scholars such as Eve tuck and Wayne
Yang Kim talbear however around the same
time we also see refusal being theorized
in other fields we see it in Black
studies and especially in Black feminist
studies with Scholars such as Tina campt
Gina Athena ulis Savannah Shanghai we
see it in pre-pandemic research on
vaccine refusal
and of course we see it in current
research about the pandemic as well as
in contemporary populist politics such
as the January 6th Insurrection we see
it in work with conscientious objectors
we see it in research with refugees who
reject the Norms of the international
Refugee regime and this last one right
is the Tibetan stance a position enacted
in a very specific and unusual political
context
in order to understand what is happening
with Tibetan immigration in North
America it's important to understand the
history of the Tibetan Refugee community
in South Asia so in 1949 Mao zedong's
people Liberation Army marched into
Tibet by 1951 had taken over the country
in the mid-1950s Tibetans began to fight
back an Eastern Tibet by 1959 the
fighting reached lhasa tibet's capital
the Dalai Lama tibet's political and
religious leader escaped into Exile in
India and thousands of Tibetans followed
him
once in India the Dalai Lama's
government immediately reconstituted
itself it remain retains today the
uncontested leadership of the Tibetan
Community the Tibetan government in
Exile is a functioning government it has
an elected Parliament it has a court
system it conducts a census it collects
taxes it runs its own school it
maintains hegemonic practices of
belonging and it is the sole
representative of over 140 000 Tibetans
resident in India and Nepal as well as
elsewhere around the world
although citizenship has been debated at
different times in Exile history it was
in the early 1960s again in the 1970s
and most recently in the last decade the
Exile government has long refused
citizenship in South Asia as part of its
political claim to Tibet
however this refusal is complicated no
country in South Asia not India not
Nepal not any other South Asian state
are signatories to the 1951 U.N
convention relating to the status of
refugees or to the 1967 protocol which
updated the convention
which what is this typical of many
countries is not the norm in South Asia
applying for and receiving un designated
convention Refugee status sets in motion
a series of rights and protections
guaranteed by the state including a path
to citizenship rather than a return to a
country where one would face political
threats
in South Asia Tibetans are refugees
without the opportunity to apply for
convention Refugee status whether they
are born in Tibet in India or in Nepal
as a result six Decades of families
multiple Generations live in South Asia
as undocumented or underdocumented
peoples right there is no path to
citizenship for them and this is unusual
right in the world
one tension of Exile sovereignty is that
individuals lack identification and life
event documents Tibetans in South Asia
hold either fake documents or locally
issued old-fashioned ones not widely
recognized outside of South Asia or they
have no documents at all in India most
but not all Tibetans hold renewable
foreigners registration certificates
referred to as arcees and identification
certificates referred to as ICS in Nepal
the situation is worse as the government
has never had an official program to
identify and provide documentation to
all Tibetan refugees although at various
points up until 1989 it did Issue some
documents to some Tibetans
the United Nations High commission for
refugees office in Kathmandu assist as a
Transit facility for Tibetans who have
escaped from Tibet and are traveling on
to India
so unlike in Palestine the United
Nations does not offer any Identity or
travel documentation to Tibetans or have
any Tibet specific offices in India or
Nepal the only document available to all
Tibetan refugees is the green book
issued by the Exile government and that
is what you can see on the screen now
these are the Green books they are
shaped like passports but they cannot be
used like one
the history of possibilities for Tibetan
citizenship in South Asia is unclear
according to the citizenship laws of
both India and Nepal many Tibetans
should qualify for citizenship in each
country either through birth or through
an established connection to the country
at several times in Exile history
vigorous discussions have taken place as
to whether or not Tibetans should seek
citizenship each time the government has
refused but tensions surround what's
perceived to be a differential
application of this refusal
as one man in India said to me the
sikhyung who is the president of the
Tibetan government and all the
government ministers have citizenship
and the benefits that come with it our
country is Tibet we are all fighting for
it but it is the ordinary Tibetans in
India Nepal who make the sacrifice of
not having citizenship end quote
in India a handful of Tibetans have
begun to make claims to citizenship as
provided in the citizenship Act of India
these claims are controversial among
Tibetans as well as among Indian
government officials the high courts
have approved citizenship for Tibetans
Tibetans excuse me only to have
government offices not recognize the
Court decisions in order to prolong
applicants Imperial Foreigner status and
again that Foreigner status is something
that dates back to the time of British
India
such claims are not possible in Nepal
where Tibetans have no name status and
where Chinese political influence has
increased greatly since the 1990s the
most recent change in India is the Tibet
Rehabilitation policy of 2014. in this
policy the government of India claimed
the right to terminate tibetan's leases
and other government grants stating
here's direct quote the Tibetans in
India are considered refugees and they
are staying temporarily in India on
humanitarian grounds end quote
the conservative Exile government
publicly claims neutrality on
citizenship for Tibetans in India
stating it is a personal decision for
people to make
privately however everyone knows you are
not supposed to apply for citizenship
privately people know that to do so
could cause problems
what happens therefore when Tibetans
leave South Asia what does refusal look
like in countries where undocumented
status is neither allowed nor advised
what options do communities have when
convention Refugee status is not a
possibility
section 134 of the U.S Immigration Act
of 1990 authorized the one-time
immigration of 1 000 in quotes displaced
Tibetans to the USA
they were chosen by Lottery and their
families allowed to join them in the U.S
after five years had passed this first
group of Tibetan immigrants paved the
way for additional groups whose
imagination was triggered by the first
following this official migration
program in the late 1990s large number
of numbers of individual Tibetans began
to migrate to North America on tourist
visas most flew into and stayed in New
York City especially in Queens
and here you see a piece of art by the
artist soda from 2014. unlike the first
official group however the later second
and third unofficial groups had nothing
waiting for them except for Tibetan
friends and family members without
citizenship and working papers they
found only certain jobs were available
and over time realized they needed
citizenship however how do you acquire
citizenship in a new country
each country's rules on this are
different
in the United States one way you might
gain citizenship is via political Asylum
the U.S government declares five groups
of people eligible for Asylum those who
have suffered persecution or feel they
were self will suffer persecution due to
race religion nationality membership and
a particular social group or political
opinion
not all Tibetans meet those
qualifications so not all qualify for
political asylum in the USA
instead they formed a new type of
citizenship migration to Canada they
have made a path from New York City to
Toronto via Buffalo and Niagara Falls go
to Buffalo everyone says you have to go
to Buffalo
in 2005 caisson phoned me in Colorado
one morning from New England I need help
she said I need to go to Buffalo
she knew I had a good friend in Toronto
who had made his way there via Buffalo
can you call him and get the information
she asked me I did and he gave me
detailed instructions and I'm going to
read them now to you verbatim take the
Greyhound bus from New York City he said
at the bus station in Buffalo get a taxi
to Viva La Casa the taxi drivers all
know this place it should be ten dollars
for the fair this is a missionary
shelter where she will be taken care of
by volunteers who will help her fill out
the Asylum forms
does she speak English she asked me no I
said then tell her to go with a friend
bring her green book her wrongs and book
and Nepali passport the story is that
she bought the passport that she's not
really a Nepali citizen it's true he
said but it's still hard to explain
Tibetans go to Buffalo to go to Canada
but why Canada why are Tibetans going to
Canada rather than staying in the U.S
the answer is simple in Canada
assessments for Asylum are reckoned
differently with tribunals determining
or not whether Tibetans qualify for
convention Refugee status not for
political Asylum
overall Tibetans have been deemed
eligible one thus appears before a judge
or tribunal with the need to convince
them that you are indeed a bona fide
Tibetan
all true or bona fide Tibetans
immediately qualify for citizenship in
Canada as well as for employment
assistance English language courses free
health care and more and of course any
bona fide Tibetan would know the exact
date of The Dalai Lama's birthday
in the 1980s
a group of Catholic men formed a rest
house for refugees fleeing war in
Central America from Guatemala from El
Salvador from Honduras at the rest house
they provided shelter meals and clothing
for the refugees but that was not all
they also provided free legal assistance
in preparing one's Asylum application
for Canada submitted all the necessary
papers and information to the Canadian
government and then drove refugees
directly to the U.S Canada border once
all of their documents were in place
the nuns named this rest house Viva la
casa
on the day I arrived at Viva La Casa my
first meeting was with the director he
and I spoke for a while about my
research then he said let's go see how
many Tibetans are here today
he explained there were 118 beds at Viva
La Casa and all were usually full
normally he said anywhere from one to
ten of those beds are occupied by
Tibetans I've worked here for four years
we've had dozens of Tibetans they are
the nicest people end quote we went to
see the assistant director to whom he
introduced me and then he asked her who
are our Tibetans this week
she paused a second and then in Surprise
said there are no Tibetans here right
now one man just left for Canada this
morning he was alone and now there are
no Tibetans in the house end quote
together they marveled at this fact that
there were no Tibetans at Viva La Casa
that morning and they reassured me that
in quotes in recent memory there hasn't
been a time when there were no Tibetans
at Viva
so you can see here is one of the um the
rooms where people stay while they are
waiting for their papers to be processed
here you have a room for children and
you can see uh kids as well as volunteer
lots of very bright and fun things to do
here
and here's something that was mentioned
to me numerous times by people I spoke
with in Toronto um the murals at Viva
and the importance of flags and you can
see down at the very bottom of the E
there in the corner of
um the E is the Tibetan flag
all the staff members had stories of
Tibetans who had stayed there and almost
every Tibetan in Toronto had a story of
staying at Viva they remembered
particular staff members or cooking food
or painting murals or picking out
clothes in the donation room before
departing for Canada they remembered
also the other refugees there from
around the world
Viva La Casa director Peter Murrell
showed me the registration books for a
four day period that month
in this period mostly individuals but
sometimes whole families had arrived
from Bangladesh Colombia Congo El
Salvador Guatemala Haiti Honduras
Nicaragua Pakistan Peru Sri Lanka
Trinidad and Tobago Zimbabwe and Tibet
there's a constant stream of people
coming in said Peter and usually five to
twelve people going to Canada each day I
say goodbye to them on the morning they
depart and I say I hope I never see you
again in other words may your Asylum
application be successful
but once at the border right how does
one prove that you are actually Tibetan
and what does it mean to be Tibetan per
the Canadian government it means one is
a Tibetan Refugee associated with the
Dalai Lama and the central Tibetan
Administration in Exile it mean when one
possesses a green book speaks Tibetan
and can narrate or otherwise perform a
convincing Tibetan identity
Tibetans have their own ideas about what
Will best display their tibetanus and of
course their ideas do not always
converge with those held by Canadian
attorneys and tribunals
speak Tibetan and wear a tuba for God's
sake one attorney told me he advised
Tibetan clients and a chuba as you can
see here is a form of Tibetan dress you
see here two elderly women in Toronto
this is in Parkdale the Tibetan
neighborhood
um the striped aprons they have over
there chuba signify that they are
married women but a form of National
Dress immediately recognizable
however not just for the elderly and
here you can see this is at the weekly
Wednesday Haka gorse in Toronto lots of
every single person dancing in this
photograph is wearing a Chupa so you can
see anyone who has that striped apron
over a signifying married woman the rest
would be unmarried women however this is
also a gender-neutral form of dress so
here more specifically you can see some
men also wearing the chuba and a couple
people some have it up over their
shoulders some have it folded it down
um again National Dress throughout Tibet
many Tibetans who speak English well use
a translator when they go before the
judge some have told me of the
experience of the Tibetan English
translator not being as fluent in
English as they are they listen to their
well-crafted answers in tibetan be
translated into a broken English Nuance
is lost detail is omitted they're deep
answers rendered Shallow by the
translator Tibetans who do not speak
English tell different stories both of
anxiety and anticipation a shared
concern all have is with what sort of
stories one is supposed to tell the
judge
as a young woman explained to me in
Queens we don't want to lie but feel
compelled to
this is not she insisted because
Tibetans are dishonest but because they
are told they need to embellish their
stories her husband added maybe they
don't really need to do that but they
hear that they do
the belief that Asylum Seekers lie
circulates globally making refugees
banal figures of distrust in New York
City Tibetans have been placed on the
list of refugees who have known stories
in the New Yorker author suketo Metta
quotes an immigration attorney who
explains to him direct quote the
immigration people know all the stories
there's one for each country there's the
Columbia rape story they all say they
were raped by farc there's the Rwanda
rape story The Tibetan Refugee Story the
details for each are the same end quote
in Toronto one internee implied to me
that Tibetan stories are often seen as
tame in comparison to those of others
direct quote some tribunal members hate
Tibetan cases because they come in after
a Rwandan guy with one arm end quote
how can tibetan's suffering compete and
how does one operate in a system that
allows suffering to be competitive or
that disqualifies individuals because of
consonants in their experiences
many Tibetans do tell the truth in
Asylum Court numerous individuals shared
with me that they told their actual
story against other advice they received
or that they spoke English rather than
Tibetan as one attorney in Toronto told
me Tibetans don't need to lie here end
quote
caisson's story didn't surprise me at
all her strategy was to answer the
judge's questions as honestly as
possible
she says I told him I threw my fake
Nepali passport into the river I wanted
to get rid of it as fast as possible
then he asked me about Tibetan culture
and I told him I was in a dance troupe
when I was younger I did one of the
dances for him right in the courtroom oh
I told him everything and I danced we
were laughing and he approved my Refugee
status so the photo you now see is of a
dance troupe that kaison was in back in
Kathmandu she is a third one from the
left wearing the green tuba with a
purple shirt underneath
so in the end there is no punch line to
the joke about the sherpa man and the
Dalai Lama's birthday
although that story was from Toronto
similar stories circulate in New York
City and throughout the Tibetan diaspora
the story about the U.S embassy official
in New Delhi who asked the non-tibetan
posing as a monk to take off his Monk's
robes and retie them and of course as
everyone listening to this story knew
the man couldn't do it
the story about the Asylum officer who
never asks about actual political
persecution
but asks instead if the petitioner knows
what the four noble truths are
as if this was Toronto rather than New
York City says a Tibetan man in Queens
and the tale about the Asylum officer
who always says no who says there is no
Tibet Tibet is a part of China and who
never grants Asylum no matter how
gruesome how devastating or how true one
story is
our research needs to recognize the
conditions and meet the needs of the
current political moment this is so for
our research topics our methods our
theories
quantitative research and also
qualitative research needs to be paired
with ethnography and vice versa together
we can see both big picture and finer
grain detail large structures and
histories as well as the lived everyday
experience kind of both wide angled
right and zoomed in views ethnography is
not just another qualitative method it
is more than that it is also
epistemology and in that it is theory
one Theory grown from ethnographic seeds
is refusal
refusal is insistence on the possible
over the probable and here I think of
Isabel stenger's Insight that if we
follow probability there is no hope just
a calculated authorization oh sorry a
calculated anticipation authorized by
the world as it is
hope combines with Will to refuse such
authorized anticipations thus moving
away from the probable into the possible
this does not happen only in courtrooms
or immigration lines but also in
everyday life it is about joking and
friendship about recalibrating new
experiences to find affordances and
attunements to long-standing ways of
being of knowing of interacting it is as
likely to take place on sidewalks and in
apartments as in attorney's offices
refusal is a form of Hope and counted
over the last 15 years I have again and
again experienced this as the remaking
of Canadian places as Tibetan places and
vice versa and so in conclusion I want
to take you to an iconic Canadian
Landmark so here we are in Tim Hortons
one summer day kesung and I went to Tim
Hortons the ubiquitous Canadian donut
and coffee shop in Jamison
he said she wanted coffee
there's better coffee down the street I
said thinking of capital espresso down
near Parkdale Community Legal Services a
building on new well where some of the
attorneys with whom I work on Asylum and
family reunification bases were based
and were signs and pamphlets were
printed in numerous languages and put up
on the wall and available on counters
including in the Tibetan language
a lifelong tea drinker k-sung said back
to me I don't really care about the
coffee I want to see who is there
continuing she said Tim Hortons is like
Cora at Boda I see everyone I know there
for Tibetans who live near the
bodachorten pictured here in Kathmandu
doing Korra or circumambulation a form
of walking meditation around the chorton
in the morning or afternoon or sometimes
both is a social activity as much as a
religious activity it is a main part of
the day for people
kiss and loved as she said this saying
there's nowhere to do Korra in Jameson
instead she said people go to Tim
Hortons to see who is already there and
to hope that someone you know will come
out as you are going in
the following spring I was in Jameson
again and stopped by the Tim Hortons on
my own two older men were going out
coming out to Young Tibetan women were
going in they saw a friend approaching
and they called out to her show
come and drink tea
so come and drink tea this is the
practice of refugee citizenship
this is refusal as possibility still
unfolding in this world
thank you
so maybe we can start with questions
from the audience
to start working with like certified
Community children in South Asia or in
general
um I could ask that question a lot thank
you for that so when I was in college I
wanted to study abroad and um
I had never left the United States
before and I learned of a study abroad
program to Nepal
and I remember the it's the first line
said Nepal is a country of superlatives
and it went on to talk about the country
as this you know from sea level to the
top of Mount Everest Hinduism Buddhism
40 different languages spoken in a
country the size of Tennessee basically
and I was captivated and decided to go
there and did and in the very first
weeks of the program
um they took us so we were a group of
maybe 20 U.S college students up to a
village close to the border with Tibet
so for anyone who's familiar with Nepal
we were in marpa which is just south of
Johnson which is just south of Houston
um and we lived there with families and
studied the Nepali Language so we stayed
there for two weeks right below kind of
10 minute walk from the village of marpa
was a Tibetan refugee camp and this was
on a trekking route and the way you
truck in Nepal um is uh where you go
hiking from Village to Village and stay
with families each night and guest house
walk back in the day now you might just
stay in a little hotel
um and you never spent really more than
one night in a place and traveling
usually in small groups so because we
were staying and we were a group of
students learning to speak Nepali we
became a tourist attraction right so
people would come to see this strange
group of American students right who
were living in the village and learning
to speak
um Nepali and what the Tibetan men and
women told me who came and they would
come each day to hang out you know in
the afternoon drink tea and just chat uh
change the whole course of my life so
again I was 20 years old at the time and
they told me they had lost their country
and that they couldn't go back at the
time there was no way to make a phone
call or to send a letter to Tibet so the
men and women I was talking to that we
left behind our parents and our brothers
and sisters and friends and grandparents
and it was had this had been 30 years
since they had left they had no
communication at all with their family
and
that alone blew my mind right at the
time there was one place you could make
a phone call and Kathmandu but I could
go there and pay money and call my
parents if I wanted to
so that was important but I it never
occurred to me you could lose your
country right and for anyone in this
room who you know works in the field of
refugee studies that is often the
position that most refugees are in right
it also hadn't occurred to them
necessarily like at that initial moment
that they were going to become refugees
or even that after the initial becoming
a refugee that they weren't going to be
going back to a renewed and and safe
landscape in just a matter of months and
so I wanted to know well what happened
and why and and why don't I know about
this
and so that was the start of me trying
to learn what had happened to educate
myself and to share that story with
others and here I am you know 30 years
later
um Tibetans now can make phone calls and
can't maybe send some packages
everything is heavily surveilled though
and censored so you have to be very
Carol careful but there is at least
communication now between families but
for the first three decades there was
none at all
um
and imagine living with that right what
would it be like to to
live your life like that not knowing the
fate of your family not being able to to
just check in
um I mean think of how connected we are
with cell phones now and how many times
think of the people you you connect with
every single day through your phone or
some sort of you know digital
um you know form of Technology even if
you don't see them face to face right
what would it be like to live without
that and without knowing so it just
that's how I got started and made a big
impression
[Music]
applying for that works and like who
gets hot and also have you encountered
people who have obtained like Indian
citizenship
so yes
um and as that one man said right that
Tibetan government officials had it
because they had to be able to travel
internationally right um and some of
them I think also appreciated the perks
that came with it right like the rights
that you do have if you have a passport
or in this country write a driver's
license right those markers those
documents of citizenship rights come
with it if you are stateless with no
documentation you literally have zero
rights right convention Refugee status
gives you some rights again but not
available to Tibetans in India
um so an RC or an IC
um registration certificates and I say I
mean I can give you the details later
there are specific thresholds you know
like if you or your parents came here
before a certain date
um so there are certain things like that
that you have to go by so many Tibetans
but not all do have these in India
um foreigners registration certificates
require renewing annually do you have to
go it often requires also paying bribes
right to get that work done or traveling
to wherever the nearest office is that
is going to to renew this for you
um so in Nepal it's not that way in
India there are forms of documentation
these are not necessarily recognized
outside of India so the Indian
government will issue a travel kind of
Visa or travel stamp on your identity
certificate and and actually in the
longer version of this talk I think
maybe I'll cut too much seems like we
have a lot of time left
um I talk about a Tibetan woman in
Toronto who traveled to Europe on this
Indian issue government issued
identities I see identity certificate
that had a stamp on it saying she could
travel internationally and she said she
landed in Europe and the immigration
officials like made fun of her you know
we're like calling people over to like
look at this and she just felt this
sense of Shame
um and so the some of the conversations
I've had with her are about how she
wants to impart secure citizenship and a
sense of security and safety for her
children right so that they don't go
through what it is she's gone through
um
but the difference kind of just to
fully pull in the idea of refusal then
between say per experience in India and
her experience now in Canada right where
she has received citizenship not refused
it right so refusing citizenship for
Tibetans in India has allowed them for a
very long time now or it's been 63 years
to argue that they are not accepting
citizenship in India or Nepal because
they are citizens of Tibet right it's
just Tibet is colonized right now by
China right so they can't you know like
can't activate to realize that
citizenship in that way but it's kind of
this deferral
so you might say okay well then if you
take citizenship in the USA or Canada or
you know France or Switzerland or all
these other countries right that don't
allow you to live in an undocumented
status for multiple Generations
um how does that impact your claim to
Tibet
and so the argument that is made is that
it enables us to fight for that claim
right it enables us to fight for that
Tibetan citizenship so in essence it's a
form of dual citizenship as I understand
it
right it's the the acquiring of Canadian
citizenship or of American citizenship
is not the um loss or denial or
forfeiture of Tibetan citizenship but
it's now a dual sort of thing right like
now with the backing of
not just a U.S or Canadian passport
um
but also that security
right and the lack of Shame the lack of
stigma the ability to act in a new way
and so that's why that line about is
kind of the the goal is the same like
the argument shifts right so when
refusal has that malleability right in
terms of what are the political needs of
the moment right and why is it perhaps
this is you know arising now
um
I was just an average reader in Texas
it's such a promoted and delighted to
hear you in person so thank you so much
for making this happen
um I actually wanted to
I've I have two sort of questions about
refusal as well the concept and as a
practice
um and you know a really picture time
building on and sort of also taking
diverse directions an existing feminist
scholarship on refusal
uh so I wanted to do if you could speak
to one which is as in
as an autograph for yourself
um
what's what is your entry point into
refusal
um in your own position as a
photographer who's sustained these
relationships maintained them committed
to them for so many years uh now so do
you
aside from
I approaching them entirely from the
perspective
we're doing this kind of refusal work
are you also as a photographer
participating in it against it within
described it so that's one question I
would like to answer
um
and secondly Within These communities of
anxiety or a fujihood refugee do or in
in places outside to bed
um
other sort of conflicts about that
refusal whether it is gendered or about
positionism class like within the
communities itself what are the kinds of
contestations about refuse or if they're
acknowledging it as sort of one practice
uh yeah those two things
um so starting with the first let's go
go in order so back to refusal as a
stance right as well as a theory
um and not everyone might be fully
familiar
um with the work but so this is really
drawing on the work of of Audra Simpson
who I mentioned for whom ethnographic
refusal is not just the study of refusal
as a political practice by a community
but also an option of the scholar right
to not disclose certain ethnographic
details or stories or even arguments
right that um that those must be held
and she posits this as not just the sort
of decisions we all have to make as
authors right in writing right you can't
put everything in so you choose to leave
some stuff out this is not that right
this is again a willful conscious
decision
to leave out things that a reader would
expect right that scholarship would
demand
that people expect to know based on the
research you did that you say I'm not
going to tell you right I'm not going to
give you the information that
ethnography or whatever your field is
Political Science History right
sociology has historically demanded
right to know based on Research
so so that just to share with folks who
aren't familiar with with um Audrey's
work
for me historically
um I have worked with refusal as a
practice of the community because that's
where I first encountered it
um and originally I wasn't doing
research on this it was just kept coming
up again and again right even before I
started the research on Asylum
um that I was so struck by the way that
um people I interacted with interacted
with consistently used the word we
refused it like that was the term they
used when they were talking about
citizenship and speaking in the
collective right not speaking
individually so I came to it that way
and that was initially the way that I
used it
um familiar with audra's work familiar
with the idea of refusal as ethnographic
stands but for me that has only come
very recently and I'll just quickly
share the story of how I've used
ethnographic refusal in my research
because I do think it's it's relevant
and that isn't just in this last year so
um one year ago actually was November
2021 I gave a lecture at the Triple A's
in Baltimore
in which I told the story of a woman
right it was kind of the ethnic
ethographic biography of one person
um and someone who had been a difficult
personality who had lived a difficult
and a very sad life
and I told her story
maybe a couple things left out not
necessarily for ethnographic refusal
more for respective for care
and I had told her story she had
recently passed away
um in conjunction with her family so her
family knew I was telling her story and
had worked with me out they hadn't read
it because it would have they didn't
want to
um but they knew I was doing this
afterwards as I Was preparing this
lecture for publication
and was you know finalizing it and and
you might know just how long this all
takes right you know like to come up
with a you know long research talk to to
convert it to an article
um I stumbled across a photo of this
woman that I had forgotten about and I
sent it to um someone in her family like
oh look I just found this old photo of
so and so
um and that person something in that
photo
um
triggered something in her and she wrote
back to me and then we talked and she
said I I don't want the story to be out
in the world anymore
and can you please stop right
I wrote back a medium and said I will
not tell that I mean I can tell the
story I'm not telling the story right
um but I said I if you don't want me to
tell this story I won't
and I'm not going to and I probably
don't make that promise to you
and I had already presented it publicly
it was already up online right as a
video lots of people had watched it lots
of people had been in the audience
um and I contacted it was AES so I was
AES had put it up it was the
distinguished lecture for AES the video
was up and I said I need you to take
down the video and the article was due
in like two days and I wrote to the
editors of the journal and I said I'm
really sorry
um I need I mean I I was going to be
ready to send it to you but I can't send
this to you now and I need to take some
time to rethink this I was scheduled to
give a talk on it in California I had to
contact those people and I said I can't
come present this talk and I need to
regroup and see if I have anything to
present to you I took a week to just
kind of ponder Ponder and think about
what to do
um and I I ended up coming up with a
plan how I could you know what happens
this that her story was the was the
heart of the talk
and I had to go deep into my notes like
into my my field notes you know going
back decades as well as into my you know
my relationships myself and I did find
stories to tell and so the article now
exists if you can go and read it it came
out in August in AE
um
but that and the article it's called
theory is ethics is is this particular
um article it was about this Theory from
ethnography it was about relationships
being at the heart of what we do right
and what does it mean to not tell a
story that the discipline
right would expect me to tell and
actually so when I did go to California
and I presented it to an
interdisciplinary audience and I kind of
shared like as I'm doing now afterwards
I had someone tell me you could have you
could have told the story anyways of
that woman
right just not getting it
um not understanding the ethics of what
it means to refuse to tell something
that's been trusted to you
um
because it would cause pain in the world
because someone else doesn't need to
know right what is our right to know
so second question refresh my memory and
then I'll sorry that was a long answer
you didn't know what you were asking
the second was about contestations
within the community on Refuge oh um
very few the Tibetan Community is
incredibly United
um there's not so much contestation as
there is
frankly jealousy
um so folks inside India especially in
India hold tight to the not gaining
citizenship nepalgan was never an issue
um so there's there's it's not like you
could have one opinion one way or the
other whereas in India there's an active
conversation on it
um it's more
you know now there's a wistfulness oh
look at those two buttons in ex-country
who have it and then you have folks
perhaps say like you know in Sunnyside
or Long Island City right it's like oh
you know our back in India we had the
following and there's
um wistfulness and Nostalgia over senses
of community and and things that were
positive about them right so there's
ways again
um there's refusals in in wanting to
cross certain lines right um but that is
very much a discourse within the Tibetan
Community what does it mean to be United
what does it mean to have an active
political struggle and the community is
incredibly United on them
grab your hand up as well yes thank you
very fascinating talk thank you
um two quick questions also so one is
about Roots I'm interested in I
considered very la casa is a very
Central node in this this move from from
America to Canada uh but but are they
also moving into Canada straight from
um from South Asia or does it have to go
fantastic yeah they are coming through
the United States
and why is that the case that because
this is Independence is individual
immigration so unless so recently there
was a citizen organized Canadian
government approved immigration plan to
bring over a group of Tibetans from
arunachal Pradesh so that group came in
directly from India and same as the
group of 1000 I was talking about before
that took place in the United States
right they came in they had a plan like
they had people waiting for them
Canadian citizens many of whom were
Tibetan Canadian citizens right jobs so
that sort of thing
um that's a group organized immigration
and authorized by the government this is
different these are individual people
appearing at the border petitioning
right for Asylum and so to do that you
cannot do that at a high commission
um it's same for the United States as
for Canada you can't go to a U.S embassy
around the world and request Asylum you
can only request that either at the
border when you're entering or once
you're in country right there's a period
of time which you can
and then related to that the new
argument about refusal is it that they
are refusing citizenship in South Asia
or are you arguing that they are
refusing the status of being
undocumented and regular and regulated
in South Asia or is it a possibility of
getting citizenship so I'm not entirely
clear but it's because I don't know much
about the future context whether you're
arguing they're refusing citizenship in
South Asia
in India or the status of not being
documented and regulated they're
refusing citizenship so since 1959 so
now we're on third even fourth
generation of Tibetans have lived in
India with either I guess it's not just
undocumented or or under right because
some of them do have these government of
India issue documentations that are good
only in India
um
the question for me actually is what
were they offered and the details of
this have never been made public either
for his Holiness the Dalai Lama's
relationships it was with nehru um in
the 1950s or with the king of Nepal
were Tibetans offered citizenship
um that I don't know for sure because
again I don't have access to the
agreements that were made the way that
the Tibetans publicly and privately
speak is that we refused it
um so it's not a protest of being
undocumented
right it's an acceptance of that but uh
but positing it as we are refusing
citizenship regardless of whether or not
it's offered to us
um again per the constitution of India
many Tibetans qualify for citizenship
however the government of India also
also doesn't
um recognize this believe me I have to
explain this all the time to judges in
Canada and the United States so it's
like well look right here in the
Constitution a Tibetan would qualify I'm
like I I understand it says that and it
looks that way
but that is not the practice which again
is why you know ethnography and lived
experience
um is as important if not more important
sometimes than what a loss is right
because actual experience
um does not correspond here with what
the legal documents say should happen
there are two questions uh okay so uh
one is that uh as we got to know about
the 1951 Refugee convention the question
uh that they're asking is why the
refugee laws came just after World War
II but not just after the 1940s and can
we look at that act as something fully
being driven it's a general question
about the 1951
okay
um
I'm not sure if the question is for the
world in general or for South Asia I
mean the answer for both is yes right I
mean that
um the formulation of refugee laws and
of unhcr following World War II right
was an attempt to solve What was seen as
you know the crisis of refugees and
stateless peoples in the world following
World War II I feel like this is um
stuff many people know
um and the agreement
um among countries that every piece of
territory had to be Associated to a
nation-state
right so there couldn't be a patch of
land that somehow was independent of you
know some State and that is where you
know refu International Refugee law
comes from in South Asia the decision
not to sign on again as a collectivity
right as um you know as a group of
states you know clearly was a political
decision that they have held to you know
ever since
um so to whoever is asking
um the answer is yes you know what that
means um for refugees in South Asia if
you recall the statement that I read
from the Tibetan Policy Act is the
government of India considers Tibetans
refugees
all right so per government of India
terminology they are refugees but that
does not align them with un convention
Refugee status which is then a shared
series of Rights or set of rights that
are supposed to be upheld right by
countries around the world that are
actionable
you know this is a different
yeah yeah sure yeah go ahead
well can you talk about the journeys of
food like refugees through Nepal and
arunachal
with like different religions different
Cuisine and outside of how that
experience to move for them was like a
world expanding experience
um culturally and um like I was struck
by that when you were talking about like
the two more dinners like the stupa and
stuff like that and I was wondering
specifically like what have what have
you observed or what if the people
you've spoken with observed about
themselves in terms of
social rules attitudes behaviors that
remain sticky for them as it was when
they lived at home versus after all
these years of like living in a
different place and navigating different
cultures and this can be used like
gender or even like teaching or
socializing or whatever
I guess two things one Tibetans are
incredibly cosmopolitan
um you know so Tibetans live in multiple
countries around the world as well as
you know the bulk of Tibetans still to
this day live inside to bed as part of
the People's Republic of China
um and each year more and more Tibetans
you come from Tibet outside especially
for education
and so there's there's lots of movement
this is a community that while for a
long time was um was very much only in
Asia for the last 20 years has become
really truly an international diaspora
so that sense of cosmopolitanism whereas
if we think of what was it that enabled
China what was one of the things anyways
that enabled China to take over to that
right to just March right in and invade
was Tibet didn't have diplomatic
relations with any countries except for
Nepal right so I mean it was the
opposite of a Cosmopolitan country right
it was very much insulated inward
focused looking at Buddhism it had not
yet entered right the world of modern
diplomacy in terms of building
relationships with other countries and
so there were no countries who then had
those sort of diplomatic
um obligations right to step in so
there's that
um but in thinking specifically about
South Asia right which is where Tibetans
came into 1959 and really up until the
year 2000 you know the overwhelming
majority right of of tibetansa we're in
South Asia
one of the big things I think that that
has been overlooked
um it has been a conservativism in
gender expression and roles right so
actually a shrinking of possibilities
for women
um and I think that is something that
has emerged from coming into society
dominated by kind of um Hindu and and
Muslim Wars right and a much more
conservative public profile for women
than um what Tibetans had experienced
um prior to that
that's something I've thought about no
end to my knowledge has actively
researched it
um but that's one thing right what does
it mean to come into a different Society
right where rules for even just like
um what parts of the body need to be
covered when you appear in public what's
considered you know decorous or not
right for a woman to how she comports
herself in public things like that
um so South Asia has has been very
influential on the Tibetan Community
um you know anyone who grew up there you
know can probably sing and dance any
number of Bollywood songs going all the
way back you know decades so like
there's there's the influences that are
beloved right and that are charming and
that are fun
um culinary influences as well and then
there's the ones that fly a little bit
lower under the surface I think such as
this conservativism not that Tibet
wasn't a conservative Society earlier
but I think it manifested itself in new
ways in Exile and gender I believe it's
one of them
here's one more question we have one uh
more questions uh
John
if you want to unmute yourself and ask
the question
yes
um in the 1960s one of the first groups
of Tibetans to leave South Asia went to
Switzerland do you know what happened to
those people and how much of a Tibetan
presence there is in Switzerland today
uh I do they are still there so until
very recently
um Switzerland you're right had the
longest standing
um kind of oldest Tibetan Community it
was kind of Switzerland in the UK
although the number of Tibetans in the
UK was also always much smaller than the
number of Switzerland
um so it's a thriving Community now and
it's now a community and Tibetans
actually are kind of throughout from
from Geneva
um
all sorts of cities in Switzerland
centered in the Zurich area and
cantonments and that um that part of the
country but now is a community that kind
of like the community in India Nepal is
is three generations deep
um so fully younger Generations fully
immersed into Swiss life whether it's
Swiss French or swiss German uh and a
very successful Community as well so
um just prior to the pandemic I was
working um on I was going to add be
adding uh France and Switzerland to my
study of refugee citizenship around the
world and I planned on spending the
summer of 2020 half in Paris and half in
Zurich and then um
the situation changed um but so I'm
hoping to go back so very active
Community there but a community that is
now truly Swiss right as well as Tibetan
yet maintaining active ties to Tibetans
around the world right there's no
Tibetan I can't think of any Tibetan
friend of mine or colleague I know who
doesn't have family members in multiple
countries around the world right so my
Swiss friends Swiss Tibetan friends you
know have relatives in DC and relatives
in Delhi and and families still inside
Tibet
um so
um an important country
um for Tibetans because Tibetans have
been resident their residents there
since the early 60s again one of those
first places outside of of South Asia
and still an active and Vibrant
Community
thank you yeah you're welcome
you want to close it or all right that's
the question oh great um I've been
thinking I've been thinking about
um both your and audra's
um concept of refusal is sort of
historically contingent modes of agency
that are made right uh differentially
available to different people and I was
struck by essentially what he said in
the essentially in the global South in
South Asia their refusal is available as
a because being undocumented and under
documented is a possibility of life
right whereas in the global North where
it is not yeah refusal looks different
and so then I think with Catherine
besteman's sort of uh militarized Global
apartheid and I'm wondering how the
Tibetan sort of situation in this sort
of different modes of agency or
different modes of refusal co-articulate
with this militarized Global party to
also bring in your wonderful book
arrested histories which deals with the
CIA history and so forth but yeah
oh absolutely I mean articulates it and
I think um what comes to me initially is
not from my own research but from Audra
so um The Scholar we're referring to
Audra Simpson has a book called mohawk
interruptus
and one of the things she talks about in
this book is not just her own crossing
of the U.S Canadian border but of the
Mohawk the Iroquois national lacrosse
team right traveling to South America
and insisting on using their Iroquois
Nation passports and then trying to come
back into so they're received they can
go to South America on those but when
they try to come back in right and what
does it mean to say right and they of
course also also right have a U.S or
have a Canadian passport what does it
mean to say I'm not going to use that
one right I think this gets into it
right like who is allowed to make what
choices who is allowed to refuse what
and this is why refusal I think as so
many of us are articulating it is
different than resistance right
resistance requires that relationship of
subjugation right it unfolds in a
landscape that's unequal right
subordination is part of resistance you
are pushing back refusal is more you
know is a horizontal relationship like I
have a U.S passport I'm not going to use
that right right I'm going to insist
right on using this other passport and
what does it take this is back to that
Tibetan woman right who felt the shame
and the stigma of showing up that like
what does it take to have that sort of
sensibility to be able to refuse
publicly when facing a security officer
like what are the stakes what are the
repercussions when can you make that
move and and when can you not right
right because there certainly are some
situations in which that is not an
option
right and resistance might not be either
right in in certain States but I would
say absolutely they
um similar things with with deep
resonance yeah it's it's it's helpful
because
on the cyclical question of agency that
keeps coming every 20 30 years
Concepts like refusal help us provide a
Topography of different modes of right
that is not do these people have agency
or don't they right so thank you for
that oh sure well thank you all and
thank you folks who are who are watching
online yeah glad you're out here